-May is the third month of
America's coronavirus quarantine
and it's also Asian-Pacific
American Heritage Month.
Here to talk about that is one
of our writers, Karen Chee.
-Hi, Seth! It's true.
This month we celebrate
Americans of Asian
and Pacific Islander heritage.
But this year has been tough,
with President Trump
calling COVID-19
the "Chinese virus"
and the news outlets almost
exclusively using photos
of Asians in their pandemic
articles,
there's been a surge in
anti-Asian racism.
Being Asian in America can feel
pretty scary right now.
So, in light of that,
I wanted to share the ways
that I'm celebrating our
heritage this month.
Number 1, be grateful.
I'm grateful for my health,
for my home,
and for the man on the street
who yelled,
"Go back to Korea!" at me.
South Korea has done
a much better job
handling the coronavirus
than the U.S.
And I would be much safer if I
went there.
So really, that man was wishing
me good health.
Thank you, kind sir!
May you also go to Korea.
Number 2, support my local
Asian-owned businesses.
A lot of Asian restaurants
and stores
are struggling right now,
because of both the coronavirus
and the added racism.
So it's essential to shop there
whenever I can.
Plus, let's be honest,
whole foods is not
gonna have my
dried squid snacks.
Number 3, defy stereotypes.
A lot of people
make assumptions about me
before they get to know me.
Specifically that I'll be
entitled, rude, and white --
just because my name is Karen!
So I'm defining stereotypes just
by being Asian.
And also, by not asking to speak
to your manager.
Number 4, keep in touch
with my family.
I call my parents every day.
And thanks to them,
I'm able to thrive indoors.
In fact, I don't long for the
outdoors at all.
Growing up, when I asked my
immigrant parents to go camping,
they were like, "Why?
We have a house.
Why would we pretend
to be homeless?"
And that prepared me well for
life in quarantine.
Number 5, celebrate our
community.
During this time,
it's important to reach out
to other members of the Asian-
Pacific American community.
Even people you may not know
that well.
And who are very hot.
Like actor John Cho.
I'm spending this month
tweeting at him --
"Hi, John Cho.
You are very hot!"
And you might say, "Karen,
that doesn't sound like
you're celebrating Asian-Pacific
American Heritage Month.
That just sounds like you're
trying to hit on John Cho."
And you would be right.
Number 6, be patient.
Quarantine is lasting a long
time, but I'm not worried.
When it ends,
I will look exactly the same
as I did when it started,
because Asians
look young forever.
Everyone at "Late Night"
thinks I'm 25,
but actually,
I'm 50 years old!
So, relax, stay inside,
and we'll celebrate in person
when the pandemic is over.
After it probably gets solved by
an Asian doctor
who my mom will want me to
marry.
-Karen Chee, everyone.
We'll be right back with
Kumail Nanjiani.